with widespread stay-at-home orders in
place and unemployment rates rising
access to food has become an even
greater concern we met Sam Samuel a
Philadelphia resident who's delivered
hundreds of meals to families in her
community earning her the nickname food
fairy in Philadelphia's Mantua
neighborhood 49 year old Sam Samuel
Rises with the Sun knowing she too has a
lot of ground to cover first she rents a
u-haul then she picks up other
volunteers and heads to a nearby
distribution center where the truck gets
loaded with hundreds of free food boxes
and milk cartons meals that would have
been available through the school's free
lunch program if not for the shutdown
caused by kovat 19 so Samuel stepped up
providing doorstep food delivery it
sounds to me like you're a
ubereats yeah for the kids
rarely does she use a street address
she knows nearly every family behind
these doors he took to overwhelm moms
like preschool teacher Natasha SAP and
her seven kids are grateful they eat
more than ever now do you have a car I
do so why aren't you picking up the food
from the distribution center well I do I
was but I can't leave them unattended
well seven kids maybe they ought to do
yes is very hard so I wouldn't need one
to put them out and risk like them and
she comes she's out faithfully
back in March Samuel was delivering
meals every day out of her van
each bag only held a day's worth of food
now students are getting a weekly box
with ten ready to go meals you started
with how many fifty I thought it was
fifty per day fifty children per day
every day every day and what are you up
to now 260 now a retired Treasury
Department employee with 25 years of
service Samuel says she's now devoted to
mantua civic association efforts
affordable food being one of them to the
store you have to go miles and miles in
order to get anything it's a desert the
community needs a supermarket last time
you saw a supermarket here in this
community 30 years or more 30 years yeah
and accessing public transportation
during the pandemic has been difficult
for 77 year old Carmen Davis and her
three grandchildren so all of them are
set down there
boxes if you didn't have this is
something that our city has never
experienced before
councilmember Jamie Gautier represents
this part of West Philadelphia and
credit school district leaders for
reopening food distribution while being
flexible in finding ways to meet federal
guidelines they have worked tirelessly
to set up food sites all over our city
and they had to do that really really
quickly but she acknowledges folks like
Samuel fill in the gaps and there's some
people who say you know she's not quite
following the rules here following the
rules around getting people food are not
as important and a global health
pandemic we have to make sure that
people eat are you pay for this no I'm
not baby at all this is all community
service and for Samuel that service
always delivers a smile I will go from
door to door every house I would make
sure that it was a child in here they
got some a box there was in a perfect
world where I could have the milkman
behind me giving each kid their milk in
their boxes that's what I would do
she's something else well in the weeks
after we saw Samuel in action buses
started running more regularly and the
school district opened a food
distribution site right in Mantua
Samuel now focuses on guiding families
to that site and offering rise to those
who can't carry those boxes home really
fascinating Michelle I mean following
the rules is very important but if he
can't eat and survive to begin with he
can't follow any of those rules right
yeah and she did it she helped get that
distribution center in Mantua her
neighborhood all right good stuff
Michelle thank you